so Dr Doom fights Kane the Conqueror and
Mephisto in the story and it's amazing
okay so check this out so this initially
picks up with something called the
antleon collider which is basically a
black hole that's being created on the
dark side of the moon it's more of a
controlled black hole it's basically a
minor Singularity but the reason why
this is done is because the world or at
least the scientific community on Earth
in the Marvel Universe wants to start
shifting more towards like nuclear power
different things like that but with all
the different forms of energy that are
used the big question that people find
themselves asking is what do we do with
all this waste right this energy waste
that we end up creating is it one of
these things where we're going to just
kind of keep on doing what we're doing
which is driving to the side of a hill
dumping our trash in the ground and then
covering it up or are we going to come
up with something that's a little more
elegant and more of afitting of our
technological advancement and so that's
the idea behind this black hole is to
literally create a place whereby trash
can be dumped essentially for Infinity
right because black holes will break
everything down on the atomic level and
it may end up filling up but I mean it's
it would take an astronomically long
amount of time in order for that to
happen the kicker to all this is that
while these interviews are being done
with members of the the antleon collider
Community they're also talking to Doctor
Doom and they asked him the question
like what's your stance on this of
course Doctor Doom being Dr Doom is like
it's gonna fail right this whole thing's
being done by Reed Richards as
intelligent as he is the biggest problem
Reed Richards has is that he's sloppy
and because he's sloppy this is going to
end up failing disastrously now the
crazy thing about this is that you do
have this guy named Steve who's one of
the guys conducting the interview right
one of these reporters and he literally
says many believe that you're just upset
because you were left out on the project
and it has to be a failure because you
weren't involved now here's the thing
right anybody who knows anything about
Doctor Doom in Marvel Comics knows that
there are some things you just don't say
right like pick your battles wisely this
is one of those because when the
interview ends Doctor Doom just kind of
leaves in a huff and then tell tells one
of his guys bring the reporter Steve to
me bring that guy to me right like I
want my hands on that guy he's been
mouthing off and we need to help Steve
understand his place in the bigger
picture and so one of the things that
kind of goes on here and it's cool is
that while that's taking place you end
up having Doctor Doom in his study and
while he's there he's suddenly met by
the arrival of King the Conqueror now
when it comes to King and Dr Doom this
is one of those things where it's kind
of you stay away I stay away right in
the sense that because these two guys
are kind of distant relations to a
degree Kang doesn't really do a whole
lot in terms of intentionally going
after Victor Von Doom the reason for
that is that in Marvel Comics it's never
been fully established if Kane the
Conqueror is the descendant of Reed
Richards or the descendant of Victor Von
Doom but the risk here and even King
himself doesn't fully know if he were to
attack Doctor Doom anywhere to kill him
who could actually prevent his own
existence from happening and so he
doesn't really go directly against Dr
Doom and usually pick a fight although
the two have fought in the past and the
fights between Dr Doom and Kang are
usually amazing like they're some of the
coolest fights you're ever gonna see
mostly because it's Kane to conquer
brandishing all his technology and time
travel escapades and his Doctor Doom was
just like the best one-liners ever in
the history of comic books it's for no
no I will say apocalypse has better
one-liners but Doctor Doom has great
one-liners he's got great lines but it's
just one of those things but it's also
because of the fact that Doctor Doom is
so astronomically intelligent and
because he's so capable and because his
lust for power in a lot of ways mirrors
that of Kang there is a kind of respect
that is grown between the two also
because of the fact they've helped each
other at different points in time and so
Kang being here is one of those things
where it's a little mysterious we don't
really know why he's here in the first
place the nature of the conversation is
really more just kind of banter back and
forth between the two and that's
basically it and then Kang ultimately
just sort of teleports away but what
Doctor Doom ends up doing is does he
prepares for bed that he actually ends
up having this vision of of a woman that
we haven't discovered yet and she and Dr
Doom have a family right like they have
a whole full-on family and so Dr Doom
really kind of going back to his
quarters right after this sort of
hallucination which really even takes
him by surprise he ends up opening the
door only to find that he's on the moon
where the entire antleon project has
gone awry according to his prediction
it's manifested a full-scale black hole
and is sucking everything in around it
now here's the thing to understand if a
black hole opened on the moon it we
would die so fast we wouldn't even be
able to understand what had happened
right like literally it would just
probably be a flash of light and like
that's it that's all we would see but
the thing about this is that once Dr
Doom of course the next morning he's
basically told hey we have Steve that uh
he ends up going to find where Steve is
basically just kind of strung up
and he's like make sure he's fed today
tomorrow we might not feed him but today
make sure he's fed and so as Dr Doom is
kind of meditating and focusing on this
Vision that he received suddenly the
nuclear arms of of latviria fire off
right they literally just start going
off like all these nuclear weapons of
ladveria shoot off they head toward the
ant Leon uh Antion collider and
basically destroy the whole thing and
because they um because they originated
from latviria and because Dr Doom had
been like yeah man uh this the whole
this whole thing's gonna fail the
immediate suspect for all of this is Dr
Doom and these guys come swooping in
right just I mean it's it's shoot out of
the okay Corral right guns blazing the
first one to show up here is Union Jack
he doesn't really matter all that much
but he is cool right he's one of these
characters where he never really gets a
whole lot of appearances in Marvel
Comics but he is cool and it is
interesting to see him from time to time
but the funny thing about this is that
while this attack's going on suddenly
Victor Von Doom is shot by Agent Zero
now Agent Zero is a lot more capable
Maverick was one of the original
inductees into the Weapon X Program
alongside Wolverine so while he's not
necessarily on the same level as
Wolverine regarding like adamantium
bonding and all that kind of stuff he is
probably one of the single greatest
assassins and mercenaries in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe it's
crazy how good he is and he even goes as
far as to say interpol's reward right
the international police the reward just
shot up for Victor Von Doom like
literally everybody's got it out for
this guy everybody's coming for this guy
and so where Dr Doom is able to
initially get the upper hand on both
Union Jack as well as as well as
Maverick he had instructed his staff
immediately issue a surrender right
immediately tell them we're surrendering
here because the worst thing we can do
is to actually face off against these
forces because what it does is it
implies guilt right like it wouldn't it
would indicate like yes we launched the
attack and I'll be damned if any is
going to come to Liberia and give me
you're never going to take me alive
right I mean it's that kind of thing
right and so ultimately he ends up
basically just surrendering to various
forces that show up here now once he's
taken he's actually brought in by a
combination of different things the
first two are silver Sable and Amy Chen
now these two are particularly important
but only in certain circles in Marvel
Comics so silver Sable runs a group
called The Wild pack which is one part
information brokering and one part
mercenary work so they are guys that
basically travel the world they pick up
people who are supposed to be picked up
by various governmental agencies or
corporations or what have you but
because silver Sable is networked with
so many different organizations and
groups out there she's basically a
person tied into a ton of information so
even if she's not necessarily coming
after you if somebody else is coming
after you they can actually hit up
silver stable and if they're able to
offer the right price she'll give them
the information that they need the other
person that's brought here is Dr Steven
strange now the reason why Steven
strange is here is one because this
story takes place before he died and two
because as most people who are familiar
with Dr Doom and Marvel Comics know Dr
Doom and Doctor Strange have a very
strong history together the most notable
instance of the two of them working
together was when they traveled to
basically the realm of Mephisto they
traveled to hell and the story
triumphant torment in order to free Dr
Doom's mother from from mephista right
to free her soul so it could go to
heaven which they successfully did and
in fact that's something that I want you
to keep in the back of your mind because
we'll talk about that again in this
story but Dr Doom's various mystical
abilities are enough that they can match
the powers of Doctor Doom so if you want
to try some crazy you know Jedi mind
trick mysticism stuff Doctor Doom would
be there to basically bring it to an end
but as we know Doctor Doom has no real
intention of doing that now the irony
behind all this and this is the
important thing to understand based on
the visions that Dr Doom has been
getting which he doesn't really know the
origin of of it and we don't really even
know the origin of it at the moment is
that these Visions indicate somewhere
along the line Dr Doom does something
which ushers in an era of peace all
across the world and literally brings a
kind of Utopia that had never been seen
before and so that's why Dr Doom 1
allows himself to surrender because he's
kind of curious about where these
Visions are leading but two Kane the
Conqueror suddenly appears inside this
ship where Dr Doom's at and it's one of
those things where literally Kings like
I've seen your future right years from
now you're the magnanimous leader of an
eternally peaceful Earth and it would be
the most preferable Earth for me to
conquer and so that's kind of the on
running theme like King the Conqueror
will appear more over the course of the
story and really if anything he kind of
shows up I mean Dr Doom does fight him a
couple times but he shows up more often
than not in order to help Doom because
he's like the things that you're gonna
do are basically going to make the earth
a Utopia but it's also going to make the
Earth weaker and it makes it easier for
me to conquer so like here's some stuff
to help you because in helping you I'm
helping myself right like that's really
what he does for a good chunk of the
story and it's hilarious the times that
he shows up it's funny but one of the
things that Doom says is okay if this
future you see is true and it matches
the visions that I've been having then
free me right like if you want to be
able to conquer the Earth in the future
because of what I'll end up doing then
free me and get me out of here and so
one of the things that they do is they
sabotage the the engines of the vessel
and then they basically Escape now you
guys are probably asking yourself why
don't they just teleport out of it the
reality is when you're dealing with king
marvel plays it fast and loose right if
Kang basically destroyed or or sabotaged
the engines it's because in looking over
all the different timelines it's the
only one where they successfully Escape
that's kind of the undercurrent that
Marvel uses right like King does
everything he does for a particular
reason but the reality is that once this
is done basically King teleports away
and Doctor Doom casts a mysticism in
order to save himself following that he
literally goes underground he Dawns a
kind of mask and hides himself and he
takes off to the city of New York now
when he gets there he basically ends up
encountering what are these sort of
visions of Morgan lafay now these
Visions come in the form of her
appearing on in like Times Square on TV
screens different things like that only
Doctor Doom can see her this is one of
those elements of Marvel Comics that's
really cool Morgan lafay has been around
for an exceedingly long time and in fact
she's been around about the same time as
Merlin in Marvel Comics and the thing
about this is she actually originates
from Atlantis or at least the Atlantean
territories before the gray cataclysm
during the second host when the
celestial showed up and then attacked
the deviants that is to say she's been
around for thousands of years and she's
incredibly powerful she's not the most
powerful person ever but it's kind of a
loose knit family between like her and
Dr Doom and Doctor Strange and like the
Scarlet Witch and brother Voodoo people
like that just these people that
practice like magic and mysticism which
is really weird when you think about it
because like there was a time when
Morgan lafaye and Doctor Doom banged so
that's kind of cool but the thing about
this is that while all that's going on
what you end up having is Reed Richards
of the Fantastic Four while it's off
panel he comes to the realization that
if Doctor Doom has actually escaped and
Dr Doom's out there on the lamb then
what they need is someone who's every
bit as intelligent as Doctor Doom
meaning this person is one it like kind
of shares the number one spot for the
smartest person in the Marvel Universe
but is also immensely powerful powerful
enough that they can stand toe-to-toe
with Dr Doom and so what you end up
having is Herbie the robot who's kind of
like the robotic assistant of the
Fantastic Four basically traveling to
Cornell and meeting with Adam Brashear
and bringing Adam Brashear in as a
person that can actually capture Dr Doom
now a lot of people are going to ask the
question how in the world is it that
like blue Marvel is on the same level as
Doctor Doom is this just something
you're making it up Rob I'm not making
this up at all and the reason why I say
that is because there's a point when
blue Marvel is meeting with with Herbie
and you know at that point you know blue
Marvel's like okay so Reed Richards is
finally taking me seriously and Herbie's
like well you were the top available
right like you were just you were the
next best choice which is kind of a
crappy way to put it but then Herbie
also goes on to say you match Doctor
Doom in intellect and strength
especially since he's without his powers
now the way that Herbie's drawing this
information is based on the information
that Reed Richards has in his database
what that means is that in Marvel Comics
what Christopher Cantwell is
establishing here that Reed Richards is
one well aware of who Adam Brashear is
which is something that we already knew
and then two looking at Adam Brashear
the blue Marvel top to bottom from his
intelligence to his strength to his
powers and so on Reed is basically
established that blue Marvel is as
intelligent and capable as Doctor Doom
what this means is that blue Marvel
shares the number one spot as the
smartest person in the world with Reed
Richards Doctor Doom and Valeria
Richards right right it's a really cool
moment this is one of those things that
you're probably going to see people
referencing when other folks ask the
question where does blue Marvel reside
in terms of intelligence strength so on
and so forth and so following this what
you end up doing is picking back up with
doom while he's traveling with Morgan
lafay and they travel to meet a guy
called the witness now this is the one
and only appearance of the witness at
least in this form that I'm aware of in
Marvel Comics but the idea behind this
guy is he can basically look into the
eyes of another person and then see
exactly what their future is and what
the witness says is that Dr Doom is
going to die and it's the saddest day on
Earth is absolutely beautiful but we
don't really find out exactly how this
death happens but what it does seem to
do is kind of fall in line with the
visions that Dr Doom's been having where
he becomes this person that literally
saves the world that it would be a
tragic and sad day because the world
would have lost somebody's significant
to them the kicker is that before any of
this goes down and any other questions
can be asked Dr Doom is killed on the
spot and he's actually assassinated and
the person who takes him out is none
other than task master Tony Masters I
told you this story gets amazing now
again in this moment what ends up
happening is because Dr Doom is by all
standards the measurement dead he wakes
up in hell he wakes up in the realm of
Mephisto and traveling there he
basically Dawns this kind of Hell armor
which I gotta tell you guys is probably
the second most badass doctor dudes ever
looked the only thing better than this
was when he was God King Doom so he
basically had his normal outfit but it
was all white which was dope and I'm
surprised no one's cosplayed as God King
Doom at any Comic Cons it kind of
astounds me but this looks dope oh my
God like it looks so obese but what ends
up happening is Doctor Doom comes face
to face with Mephisto now the thing
about this is Doctor Doom tells him
right off the bat I'm not supposed to be
here and the response of Mephisto is
that's what they all say but I'm glad to
have your your soul now and forever and
Doctor Doom immediately attacks Mephisto
now here's the thing to understand about
Mephisto right this guy is a misnomer
when it comes to how powerful the Fisto
is with with Mephisto himself he is at
the peak of his power when he's in his
own realm but he's not indestructible
and he's not Unstoppable but the thing
about this is that Doctor Doom is
immensely powerful the reality here is
Doctor Doom's not powerful enough to
overcome Mephisto to beat him in his own
realm like this and so what kind of goes
on here is a bit of bouncing back and
forth where Mephisto starts playing
games with Dr Doom now one of the other
things that I want to establish here is
really kind of more of a background of
what's taking place is that you do have
the kingdom of latviria where Doctor
Doom normally resides what you have next
to it is a place called simcaria and
socari has kind of been a war-torn place
for quite some time only recently has it
actually established any measure of an
organized government and so what's going
on here is that simcaria is actually
actually organizing battle formations
and they're in the process of trying to
conquer Liberia while Dr Doom is not
there so that's an important plot point
to keep in mind again we're not going to
be talking a lot about that but we will
talk about it at the end because it does
become incredibly important at the end
of this but the thing about this kind of
focusing on the Here and Now what
Mephisto does is he tells Dr Doom if you
can convince Valeria that you deserve to
live then you can return to your life
now here's the thing Valeria there's two
different ones there's Valeria Richards
who's the daughter of Reed Richards and
then there's a different Valeria so no
we're not talking about you know Valeria
Richards right this 11 year old kid that
Dr Doom was in love with that's weird
right that's weird and creepy and really
really gross Valeria is a character
who's exceedingly old school in Marvel
Comics and in fact she goes all the way
back to Marvel Superheroes number 20 in
1969 Valeria was a person who lived in
the same camp that Dr Doom did when he
was a little kid they were basically you
know they they kind of fell in love as
teenagers as much as anybody could but
it's not Dr Doom became consumed by
Vengeance and power Valeria basically
left him behind right she just didn't
want to be a part of that life and as a
result of that she eventually fled Dr
Doom caught up to her and basically
convinced her that he was going to leave
all that Madness behind and all he
wanted was her love and a life and so
she ultimately bought into it what was
really going on and probably one of the
most just amazing stories that Mark raid
ever wrote In The Fantastic Four back in
volume three back in 2003 the idea here
is that what Dr Doom had done is he had
actually tricked Valeria and he
effectively sold her soul behind her
back so that he could attain mystical
armor right enhance his powers and so
when that happened her soul was sent to
the realm of Mephisto it was a pretty
shady thing to do and that's why
Mephisto makes this claim if you can
convince the only woman in the world who
ever loved you that you betrayed her
that you deserve life then I will give
it to you and that's the crazy thing is
Victor Von Doom tries to do it any even
tries to rationalize his actions no no I
needed that because I'm going to make
the world a better place I'm going to
make the world a way more interesting
place your your soul right Eternal
damnation for you that was a sacrifice I
was willing to make in order to make
that happen right the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few the
reality here is he's not really
apologetic for it and so in spewing all
this stuff about everything he's seen
suddenly you end up having Valeria that
transforms into a demon really in like
really Mephisto this kind of been
impersonating her and then the like
really tormenting Dr Doom and it's like
I've seen this life that you say you've
seen Doctor Doom I see how you save
everything and so on and so forth you're
never going to attain it that's going to
be your damnation here right your
eternal torment is going to be that you
know without a shadow of a doubt that
your one dream in this world actually
comes true that you become this leader
of this Earth You Lead it into Utopia
you become everything that you believe
yourself to be and you're never going to
be able to attain it that that's going
to be your health and so literally a
fight breaks out between the two and
it's pretty knocked down drag out but in
the middle of all this mistress death
appears and is like done this fight's
over right he will return to his life
Mephisto now here's the thing even
Mephisto himself regardless of any level
his level of power he has is not stupid
enough to fight mistress death She's the
literal living embodiment of death all
she has to do is will it and Mephisto
ceases to exist that's it I mean that's
literally what you're talking about here
so not even he is stupid enough to
invoke her ire and the funny thing about
this is that where Dr Doom asks right
like are you doing this so that I can
truly go back to Earth and become the
person that saves it and her response is
no it's because you will become my
greatest servant of all you will bring a
level of death and destruction that the
world has never seen it's a crazy thing
because what ends up happening is that
after this whole circumstance arrives or
it really ends that Doctor Doom wakes up
in the home of Morgan lafay who had
taken his body back to her apartment and
of course the two of them are joined by
by Blue Marvel now as soon as Dr Doom
sees Adam Brashear he immediately fires
on him and gets him out of there because
Doctor Doom knows how powerful Adam
Brashear is he knows how capable he is
and if a true knockdown drag out fight
between the two happens that given his
current circumstance it's highly
unlikely that Dr Doom will be able to
overpower Adam Brashear and basically
keep him from from being arrested right
so that's why he literally sends him
flying in the moment to sort of get him
out of the way at that point yet again
Kate the Conqueror pops up
Kane the Conqueror appears and it's one
of those things where it's kind of an
information brokering right at that
point doctor Doom's like okay King I
need you to Rattle your brain I need you
to tell me what timelines there are
where I was successfully killed in this
moment Here and Now not five days ago
right not 50 minutes ago if this moment
right now I need to know who it was that
killed me and the response of King is it
was Tasman master and he was hired by
Advanced idea mechanics and so what
literally ends up happening here is Dr
Doom finds the base of advanced idea
mechanics right he literally breaks in
he steals their weapons and starts
shooting the place up he kills everyone
right he does he like every single
soldier they have they all die now
here's the thing I had previously stated
that Dr Doom without his powers is
basically useless I was wrong right I
was 100 wrong unlike most people on the
internet I can admit when I'm wrong when
I'm when I think I'm wrong unfortunately
I usually never think I'm wrong so I
usually never admit when I am wrong just
kidding but here's one of the things
right I never really considered Doctor
Doom to be capable when he didn't have
his arms and Armament this dude's a
beast man this guy's rolling through
here with just with just the biggest gun
I've ever seen killing everyone he sees
right just overpowering them all he
duplicates himself several times over
and all those different forces right all
those different versions of himself
start attacking all the these different
soldiers so we still use those powers to
a degree but at the end of the day it
comes down to him and Taskmaster now
this is when you really get to see what
Dr Doom is capable of I never believed
he was good when it came to hand-to-hand
combat mostly because you never really
see him doing hand-to-hand combat it's
always like you know I'm Dr Doom and
magical spells and just badassery all
over the place that's usually all you
ever see but seeing him facing off
against Taskmaster like this and
overcoming Tony Masters is impressive as
hell right it's a pretty pretty cool
thing because remember when you're
fighting against Taskmaster you're not
just fighting Tony Masters you're
fighting everyone Tony Masters has ever
fought right so you're fighting Captain
America Spider-Man Deadpool Wolverine
like all these different characters
because this is a Rolodex he just pulls
those fighting styles out and depending
on the circumstance especially when he
was fighting black panther he actually
merged all those fighting styles into
one to where he would punch like Captain
America but he would Dodge like
Spider-Man and he would kick like
Deadpool it was cool man it was it was
one of the coolest things just some
amazing moments that you see in Marvel
Comics and so once Dr Doom gets the
upper hand on Taskmaster knowing that
taskmaster's mission was quote unquote
finished with Dr Doom the next thing he
wants to know is who are you supposed to
go after next right because he literally
asked him who hired Advanced idea
mechanics to kill me right that's what I
want to know who hired them to take me
out who hired you to take me out and
where he initially won't give that
explanation the reality here is Doctor
Doom's smart enough to know that if
Taskmaster is going after Doctor Doom
then Taskmaster is also going after
people associated with Dr Doom and so
that's when he's like I want to know who
this is who is it you're supposed to go
after next and that's when he says it's
for Xena right it's a woman named for
Xena and at that moment Doctor Doom
basically ends up realizing there's a
much bigger thing going on here and
immediately goes after that chick right
immediately goes after for Xena now the
other thing that takes place here is
kind of working his ranks up right
basically continuing to take out task
master as well as what seemingly the
rest of advanced idea mechanics he's met
by the arrival of Modoc now Modoc
doesn't really offer much in the way of
a challenge here for Dr Doom he kind of
does but he kind of doesn't he tries to
shoot him with like a mental blast Dr
Doom has the shield of Taskmaster and
his sword he just stabs Modoc in the
chest but this killing is also a long
time coming because remember Modoc was
part of Intelligentsia which was the
organization that stripped Doctor Doom
of his intelligence if you're not
familiar with that storyline we're
actually covering it right now in my
videos on Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four so we'll post a link to that video
down in the playlist but in the midst of
all this you end up picking up on
Liberty Island now Liberty Island is a
place that has these kind of weather
stations that are being created or being
used by this woman named for Xena and
the idea behind this is it's basically
an attempt even if only in a smaller
localized space to basically control
weather in Marvel Comics that kind of
stuff happens all the time it's not
really a new thing it's not really
Landmark it's just something that
Christopher cantwell's throwing in here
to show what she's doing but in the
midst of all this one of the things that
we learned is she is from latviria and
we know this because there are
discussion does it take place between
her and the people around her where they
ask questions like you know is Doctor
Doom really an effective leader you know
is it a good thing that he's gone that
kind of stuff and she's like understand
right the law of sedition and rendition
those individuals who speak ill of
latviria and its leader especially
Liberian citizens will literally be
tossed in some kind of a re-education
camp I don't want to be one of those
guys so I'm going to go back to doing
what I was doing right that kind of a
thing it's just kind of bred into them
in terms of how they function the other
part of this here is that while you do
have Doctor Doom in a library who's
basically reading up on for Xena the
reason why this name is so significant
comes when he's visited by Kane the
Conqueror yet again and when when the
the two of them really start talking is
Doctor Doom saying in these visions that
I had the woman that I end up marrying
is for Xena like that's the person that
I end up marrying and that I end up
having a life with so the reality is if
she's a target of advanced idea
mechanics and they're looking to kill
her by using Taskmaster or somebody I've
got to find a way to keep her alive
she's supposed to end up becoming my
wife and so this is a really significant
moment here and there's actually history
between Doctor Doom and forsina
indirectly and the reason why this
happens is because you do have a little
bit of a skirmish that takes place
between Dr Doom and Kane the Conqueror
but the significance of this really
comes in the form of the fact that when
Dr Doom ends up visiting for Xena she
initially rebukes him right I mean at
first she's kind of like oh my God it's
Lord Doctor Doom you know that kind of a
thing but once the veil goes away and he
tells her just address me like a regular
person she doesn't like him and in fact
she hates him because he tells her like
I've had visions and you and I are
supposed to get married which is one way
to propose right just like run up on a
random chick hey random woman over there
I've had Visions we're supposed to get
married uh you want to get hitched right
that's not gonna work
but the reason why frezina hates Doctor
Doom is because there was a point during
doomor when Dr Doom had invaded wakanda
and stole its vibranium that a
journalist in Liberia had spoken out
against Dr Doom because of that and what
Dr Doom had done is he had jailed that
guy basically for forced Edition right
for speaking ill of vladviria and of
Doctor Doom and that guy is still
serving a prison sentence that guy is
the father of farsina and that's why she
hates Dr Doom because the guy was just
doing his job and the price he paid is
is basically a life of imprisonment and
even Dr Doom goes as far as to say I
should have had your father executed for
what he did just be happy in the fact
that I didn't and I was feeling
particularly generous now that's the
most Doctor Doom thing to say to be
honest with you but in the midst of all
this a couple things happen the first is
that you basically have the arrival of
Adam Brashear alongside Herbie and then
you have the arrival of silver Sable and
Victorious now I've kind of held off on
talking about them up to this point the
way things that played out with their
characters is that Victorious was kind
of like the second in command to Doctor
Doom whenever he's not in Liberia she's
the one who runs the show and so where
you basically had the samkarians who
were attempting to invade latviria
successfully did so and then took over
the country that Victorious was
basically ousted but the other part of
this is that silver Sable being as smart
as she is had realized something else is
going on here and she was actually being
used and so she and Victorious work
together to try to find Doctor Doom so
they could basically put all their
information together and figure out what
the bigger picture is now of course blue
Marvel being here is just for the
purpose of trying to you know to grab
Doctor Doom and it's really an amazing
moment because a fight breaks out
between the two and Adam Brashear holds
his own against Doctor Doom and that's
one of the things that I hope you notice
here in terms of Doctor Doom facing off
against uh against Blue Marvel it's
really him just trying to hold off the
power of Adam Brashear and this is due
to the fact that in this moment Doctor
Doom is not as powerful as Adam Brashear
it's a pretty cool moment right it's a
pretty cool and badass thing we're
literally blue Marvel is more powerful
than Dr Doom In This Moment now of
course yet again K the Conqueror shows
up
I told you he would show up at like the
funniest moments and at the most
inopportune times what's really cool
though is that this is an exceedingly
opportune time he shows up here with
just this insane weapon and it's like
okay Doctor Doom this is for you because
remember you gotta live so that you can
make the world easier to conquer for me
like I told you as his whole motivation
is showing up here strictly for that and
in fact what you end up having is Adam
Brashear who immediately attacks Kane
the Conqueror because Kane the Conqueror
destroys Herbie and so in that moment
Adam Brashear like the blue Marvel kills
Kane the Conqueror right he kills him on
the spot just incinerates that guy and
that's when doctor Doom's like okay yeah
we gotta get out of here like we gotta
find a way to bail the other part of
this though is that no one's prepared
for what comes next because what happens
here is that with Kane the Conqueror it
wasn't simply just a weapon in that he
gave Dr Doom what he also gave him was
an advanced suit of armor from his own
timeline right from Kang's own timeline
in doing that what it does is it
restores Victor Von Doom back to his
full power he's got the full run of his
technology combined with his mysticism
and advanced Weaponry from Kane the
Conqueror blue Marble's like look here's
the thing Doom we have to put these
grievances aside this black hole is
going to emerge everything's going nuts
with the antleon collider we have to do
something and the response of Doctor
Doom is no like I'm not going to do that
I'm going to go home and I'm gonna take
care of my country Reed Richards wanted
to be the one to run the show that let
Reid Richards run the show and if the
entirety of the project goes awry and a
black hole Singularity opens at the Moon
I will deal with it and I will take care
of it but I will take care of it because
I'm better than he is but I want the
world to know that Reed Richards is a
failure I want the world to know that
he's nowhere near as capable as I am
literally Doctor Doom is willing to
potentially see the Earth destroyed just
to make Reed Richards look bad but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace